In order to get married in Kenya, the groom's
family has to provide a dowry of at least
10 cows to the bride's family.
Before Beverly Hills was home to the rich
and famous, the area was better known for
its lima beans.
The Vatican City is now home to the Pope and
all his predecessors, but not before the 14th
century.
Popes used to live in the Lateran Palace in
Rome, and even in France, for a brief period.
In the state of Idaho, you are prohibited
by law to go fishing on the back of a camel
or a giraffe.
A building in New York has been built out
of mushrooms.
The mushrooms are grown in a brick mold and
then set in a building.
The longest continuous sidewalk in the world
is along Bay Shore Boulevard in Tampa, Florida.
In Vermont, billboards are illegal; to ensure
that drivers and passengers can freely admire
the natural beauty.
Andrew Jackson was the only US President to
have the national debt paid in full.
The Procrastinators' Club of America newsletter
is called “Last Month's Newsletter.”
Philip Morris once ran an ad acknowledging
“smokers' cough.”
They claimed it was caused by smoking brands
other than Philip Morris.
University of Louisville Police arrested a
man for stealing a book titled "Resolving
Ethical Issues" and trying to sell it to the
bookstore.
26 miles of unwrapped steel was used to construct
China's huge “Bird's Nest” stadium—making
it the largest steel structure in the world.
America's first "Air Force" was equipped with
five hot-air balloons and fifty servicemen.
New Hampshire is the only U.S. state that
does not lawfully require drivers to wear
safety belts while operating a motor vehicle.
George Washington grew marijuana at his farm.
Those doves released at weddings and other
formal ceremonies are actually white homing
pigeons.
True ring-neck doves are bred to be kept as
pets and rarely survive out of captivity.